can you make money off short films
you can that was always my uh
my curiosity back when i was still
unsure
what's the future of short films i don't
really understand where they can be
distributed
um the obvious answer was youtube you
can absolutely
put them up on youtube now i think most
many people understand the
parameters of youtube you have to have
something like 4
000 watch hours on your channel and at
least a thousand subscribers i believe
it is before you can monetize
and then once you monetize you can play
ads you know ads in the beginning and
middle um and so you can start
monetizing now
i'm a a career in youtube
i think if you're doing a certain type
of content like let's say vlogging or
tutorial work or you know something like
that um
perhaps the hours and the uh
the expense and the production is a
slightly more trimmed down
output you know whereas you can maybe
start turning a more
livable profit off of it for our channel
you know i
certainly have grand designs for where
it can go and what kind of income it can
make for us
it makes a a respectable polite income
for us right now
it's not turning any heads but i i it
you know it's kind of it's nice to see
something come in for
short films that we just kind of crafted
from our own design
and kind of threw up there i mean not
just throughout we spend quite a bit of
time
but you know it was nothing a month ago
and now we put it up and it's gonna make
us
it'll just keep making us money in
perpetuity for as long as youtube exists
and people watch
have any producers reached out to you
because of the success of diet or your
youtube channel
yes and that's that's really what i
would say the value
add for doing these short films is
growing your network and
and growing your network into a a pool
that you might not have otherwise had
access to
because you're showing our youtube
channel is now more of like a portfolio
of
our work um as much as it's like our
channel of fun it's also
our work and this is we're showing off
like what we can create
and we've had a few producers reach out
to us and
be very very complimentary of the shorts
and i you know i
like to think that they get to know us a
little bit in the making of videos that
we post after every short
and that that goes a long way too people
kind of want to get to know the person
they're working
or might work with um and see that
they're
nice i think we're nice uh people and
and i think that that's been helpful
both the
quality of work and then the making of
to get to get to get to know us a little
bit better
um has allowed us to have quite like a
decent little bit of success of people
reaching out to us
asking us what we have available what
scripts do we have like what ideas do we
have
and it's been a very different
conversation you know whereas before
the conversation might have been a
teensy bit more nerve-wracking where
we're like
my god i hope they like this idea please
please i can't believe we got the
meeting thank goodness you know a little
bit more like we're at the mercy of
this this meeting that we're taking now
you know and i'm certainly not
like trying to um say i'm like being
green lit any day
tomorrow but we're having very different
conversations with these producers where
they know our work and they're like we
love what you're doing you know like why
don't let's start talking about
something that's amazing what do you
guys want to make it's a little bit more
open like that
and i mean isn't that the dream to sit
next to someone who can kind of
greenlight your project and they're
saying what is it that you want to make
you're like
let me tell you you know and then we
have all our ideas and then we we then
go into the pitch so it's pretty
exciting
and these are people who approach you
via email or they also approach you on
social media
um no they they approach us via email so
that's been that's been really great
yeah
and yeah just still see what the future
holds there what tips do you have for
others on making short films
i think i i kind of uh i have like my
at-home jargon that i use and so i kind
of
call some of our shorts home brewed
which does it kind of i think maybe
sounds negative but it just means
you know what's something aaron and i
can shoot at home
very little money you know we don't need
to order any big set pieces we don't
have to hire any big professionals to
come do anything for us he's got his
camera i can be the actress what can we
do like that
so that's what i call like our home
brewed shorts and then i call the other
ones like our tent poles like the ones
that are like okay we need to get a
professional
special effects artist over here we need
to create this giant set piece you know
like those are like the bigger leads
i see a lot of filmmakers living in this
world the tentpole shorts
and that's great you know you do need
several of them
try not my advice would be not to tie up
all of your time and resources and money
only here in the tent polls cast more uh
you know irons in the fire
by doing some more smaller stories you
can still have a lot
of quality you can tell great stories if
horror is your game or
you know whatever your genre is you can
tell great
tight stories in shorts that are home
brewed and and
you know put yourself in a box more of a
creative box like okay
i'm going to challenge myself for this
short to only spend a maximum of 20
you know and perhaps that's just going
to be your chipotle order for the day or
whatever
um but you can absolutely you can
absolutely do it and even if it means
you only have your cell phone to shoot
on
put yourself in that box okay that's my
resource i only have
my my phone so that means i'm probably
going to be limited
probably to sort of found footage style
okay let me write a tight little short
that's
in that box what what's kind of new on a
found footage
that i can shoot in a home boot category
and save my resources for just
maybe a few like a smaller amount of
these tent pole shorts you know that way
you're constantly brewing things you
have your big ones your your crowd
pleasers
you've got your other ones that are so
thrilling and exciting um but you're
constantly putting out content you're
constantly crafting
uh your your skills you're really
sharpening that by working more
frequently
you have a marketing background i do yes
how has that helped with creating
content on youtube
well my background come you know
when i was in college i kind of went for
pr and advertising and then my first job
i was able to just launch into branding
and and branding
was everything that ended up being the
you know wax on wax off of my of my
career where
all of a sudden i think i'm just
building brands for logos and little
website you know smaller websites for
small companies
and then you know one day you realize
you know karate and you can launch your
own production company with your own
slick
cohesive branding because you've been
doing this for years with other people
and now you get to follow your passion
and like
be a filmmaker so my
brand my brand background my marketing
skills lean
pretty heavily in both technical and i
would say in other area that's a little
bit harder to quantify but it's
confidence so because i feel so
confident i've been doing this for so
long i've pitched i've made press
releases i've done it all
i'm like oh our channel no problem i'll
email anyone like i have this confidence
to me because i know the metrics i know
exactly what to read
i know exactly what if i want to secure
a brand deal what the
cost per milli should be you know it's
like that information is constantly up
here
and it's always present in my mind and
so i do think that that
branding transcends to our features our
production company and our youtube
channel it's
it's is omnipresent the right word if no
omni is only for god but
you understand i was like i shouldn't
say omnipresent for marketing marketing
is not god
when you were in maryland and you were
you were i think that's where your first
job was
after you attended college did you ever
envision that you would be
in la doing oh my god film no
i didn't i mean i i could have only
dreamt to do that
like uh the so when i was in college i
re i
you know your passion you know you you
kind of know secretly what your passion
is even if you're too afraid to pursue
it
i didn't have any idea how i could make
a
financial like a living a sound living
in filmmaking
i don't even know i wouldn't maybe to
even be an actress then like how am i
going to break through all the noise
and become an actress who can actually
pay her bills complete unknown there
so in college i thought well i can still
be kind of creative in advertising
advertising i might be lucky enough to
work at an ad agency
and craft commercials you know and maybe
i can
uh you know storyboard some commercials
maybe i can like script some of them
that would have been
at the time my highest possible
thought that i could have achieved which
i think now kind of sounds a little sad
because i should have always believed in
myself and believed that anything was
possible but
there's just the hard truth of reality
like no one else is going to pay my rent
i need i need to pay these bills like
and
i need to have savings that's life
that's the truth of life it's how am i
going to make this living
um and so anyways it was kind of like a
series of unfortunate events that
allowed me to even come out to
california the biggest blessing in my
entire life
i happened to get that the company was
downsized so my
almost entire department was downsized
and eventually i was let go
or i guess downsized was the right word
um and then
it was right around like thanksgiving
i've lived in baltimore so like their
homes are
like they're called row homes because
they're all kind of like squished
together
um a neighbor had fallen asleep and like
while their
kit like something was cooking in their
kitchen so their house went up in flames
no one's hurt thank god
but my home my i rented uh was
completely destroyed it was like
complete smoke damage like
i basically lost everything and then uh
my car had been completely totaled by
the the company that comes to you know
get all the smoke damage out of houses
so within the span of like two or three
months i had
lost my job uh lost my home and
lost my car my transportation and i'd
been doing gig jobs at the time so i
absolutely needed my car to get around
and you know you kind of just look at
something like that and you think like
this might be a good time for a fresh
start something's telling me it might be
time to
go higher like go follow some passions
here because what's the worst that can
happen i'm already looking at some
some rough times and also keep in mind i
was you know a bit younger then so
you're a little bit more
footloose and fancy free so i thought
new york is pretty close to maryland i
could take a train up there
miami okay i have some family in florida
that's interesting
and then there was california i didn't
know anyone in california
california if someone even told me that
they visited california
i thought they were the coolest person
in the entire universe
the idea that i could live in california
that would have been that was the brave
move i was like i must do it you must
follow do it it's scary but do it
so you know i packed up what whatever i
had it wasn't like smelled like campfire
in my cat
and flew across the country and and
that's that was it and it was the
best happiest just oh i'm so great i'm
so grateful i'm grateful every single
day that that happened because
that allowed me to get into filmmaking
and meet some incredible people and have
just really like life-changing
experiences in creativity and
newness and openness and of course meet
aaron who is
my partner in all things and really like
my godsend when it comes to filmmaking
because what i
don't know about filmmaking he knows and
and that's been fantastic
and your instagram hadn't you hadn't
grown it at that point
oh no i think i had like a picture of a
hot chocolate in my cat on my instagram
at the time
that was about it yeah but i at the time
i was able to take
you know my marketing skills and be like
okay i think i can be a marketing
consultant i've been doing this for this
company for a while so let me go ahead
and offer this skill and and so i was
able to find a client or two to like
kind of
get some some you know foothold in a
business world
and that's kind of what i started
pursuing when it came out to california
i didn't want to be
i didn't even know how to to do anything
else i was just like let's just try
um and then along the way you know
obviously i met jake and logan paul and
they showed me what social media
business could be and i thought
i can do that i can try at least to do
that
and i started taking that very seriously
and and just
i mean it is a hustle like but it's a
happy hustle you know you're
you're trying things you're exploring
you're figuring out your own self
throughout the process and
and you know it's wild and it's fun and
and then you you kind of land at this
beautiful precipice of filmmaking for me
something that was my childhood dream
that i had tucked away because
i didn't think i could ever make a
living doing it and it's still a
struggle today but it's like a happy
struggle because i'm
i'm figuring it out and i can see
exactly what i need to do and just keep
doing it and
over time you'll get where you want to
go and so that would be feedback
or i'm sorry that's like advice i would
give to anyone else is just
you know follow that gut take it take a
chance and just kind of let
let experiences inform your next choice
you know try and roll with it and learn
what you can
filter out what you don't need just keep
moving forward
wow what a story what a story thank you
yeah because those are all like major
things that are that could make people
go
you know get very depressed but you
decided to just say you know what i'm
gonna
oh yeah yeah and that's a little bit why
i say i was a slightly younger age at
the time because i think if you're
maybe older i don't i don't want to
generalize everything's different for
other people but
it can the world can start to feel a
little bit scarier as you go either
more bravery to do things like that when
you're a little bit younger you're like
whatever if i
fall on my feet or follow my butt i'll
just i don't know
knock on mom's door hopefully she'll let
me you know something like that
um but you know it does take a little
bit of bravery and and it's a
really phenomenal payoff very cool thank
you